sin muy buenos días desde nueva york
puesto el discurso de áñez quizá fue uno
de los más nacionales electorales que
hemos escuchado en estos días quizá por
esas elecciones que están a la vuelta de
la esquina al 18 de octubre
áñez dijo que américa latina se
encuentra en un momento en el que tiene
que elegir entre dictadura o democracia
y no se trata de la gira entre la
derecha o la izquierda sino en decidir
si queremos ir por el camino de la
libertad o del lado de la opresión como
decías también hizo hincapié en ese
acoso sistemático al que está sometido a
bolivia por parte de argentina dijo que
argentina actúa en contra de los valores
e instituciones bolivianos lo que frenan
la libertad año' dijo también que no
tiene nada en contra de argentina pero
denunció que el presidente de argentina
está interfiriendo en la política de su
país de bolivia ayer también se anunció
la celebración de un evento que tendrá
lugar el día 12 de diciembre encabezado
por el secretario general de las
naciones unidas
antonio gutiérrez del primer ministro
británico boris johnson que será
celebrado el 12 de diciembre y se
centrará en el cambio climático
coincidiendo con el quinto aniversario
de esa firma del acuerdo de parís a esa
reunión asistirán los mandatarios más
comprometidos con acabar con el cambio
climático para presentar nuevos
compromisos financieros y que podemos
esperar para la jornada de hoy jueves
y hoy será el turno de la mayoría de los
líderes africanos
de naciones como congo gambia o botsuana
será el turno también del mandatario del
salvador
bukele que lo recordará en el año pasado
hizo este es el fin desde la tribuna del
hemiciclo denunciando un poco pues que
ya era hora de que la onu se modernizará
pues bien como si no una premonición se
tratara este año intervendrá también de
manera virtual la pandemia estará dentro
de sus de su discurso por supuesto como
también lo estará dentro de los
discursos del mandatario de libia y de
yemen que también será hoy su turno
justo libia llega en un momento en el
que el representante elegido por el
secretario general de las naciones
unidas antonio guterres renunció a su
cargo en marzo después de dos años será
el puesto gracias a mamen por este
completísimo reporte de nueva york